[Music]
Biodiversity and ecosystem performance are
essential for the survival of all people in Europe. The loss of this
nature not only destroys
people's livelihoods but also their sense of home. We have to
protect them and at the same time
securing our food supply
with and in nature must be and
remain my task  Today I would like to
express my appreciation to our farmers,
my appreciation and my thanks for
providing us with food every day. Healthy
food for us in Europe. This
task of agriculture is the basis
of agricultural policy. Many are already committed
to more sustainable
agriculture. We have to work together
to overcome this new challenge with the people in agriculture
and for this reason we would like to start a
strategic dialogue on the future of
agriculture in Europe
because I am and remain
convinced that agriculture and
nature conservation can go together -
both are
important